اخذت الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل على ما بات
يسمى بالانقلاب على نظام القضاء منحا
دراماتيكيا حيث ضربت مركز الاجماع في
اسرائيل الجيش بعد ان اعلن معظم ضباط
الاحتياط في احد اهم اسراب القتال في سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي رفضهم الاتحاد بمناوره
جويه الاربعاء وهم ممن يشاركون في الغارات
على سوريا سبق ذلك اعلان مئات الضباط من
وحدات خاصه العصيان ايضا وعدد من ضباط
وحده استخباراتيه ما دفع جميع قاده سلاح
الجو المتعاقبين في اسرائيل الى توجيه
نداء لنتنياهو بوقف تشريع خطه تغيير نظام
القضاء منعا الانهيار احد اهم اركان
المجتمع في اسرائيل
الوضع اليوم يحتم علينا اجراء حوار سريع
تمثل امامنا تحديات خارجيه ثقيله ومركبه
وكل دعوه لرفض الخدمه العسكريه تمس باداء
الجيش وبقدرته على القيام بمهامه
الخشيه داخل المؤسسه العسكريه مزدوجه فمن
ناحيه هناك قلق من تاثير موجه العصيان
امتدت على الاداء القتالي للجيش ما قد
يرتسم ضعفا يغري جهات خارجيه لاختبار
عسكريا ومن ناحيه ثانيه تفكك العلاقات
الداخليه في الجيش الاسرائيلي وتسييسه قد
يؤدي الى تفككه
بالطبع واستمرار للنقاش هذه الايام حول
رفض الخدمه العسكريه فانا ضد اي عصيان لان
الخدمه في الجيش قيمه العليا لكن هناك حدا
لتلون الحكومه عند الحديث عن ذلك الى جانب
القلق من اقحام الجيش في صراع الداخلي فان
هناك قلقا لدى دوائر استراتيجيه اسرائيليه
من ان المازق السياسي القضائي ووجود وزراء
متطرفين قد يعمق ازمه العلاقات مع واشنطن
التي لا تستطيع اسرائيل التخلي عنها في
مواجهه النووي الايراني وملفات اخرى
يبدو ان احتدام المواجهه بين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والاغلبيه المعارضه لخطه
اضعاف القضاء على الاقل وفق استطلاعات
الراي بات يهدد وحده الجيش الاسرائيلي في
حاله تسعات رقعه العصيان العسكري واستمرت
الحكومه في هرولتها نحو تطبيق الخطه زياد
حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه